madame monsieur bonsoir où en est-on
dans les hôpitaux en france
oublions un instant les négociations les
mots d'ordre pour aller à la réalité
voici trois semaines maintenant que les
infirmières et les personnels
hospitaliers sont en grève dans leur
ensemble les médecins à commencer par
quelques grands patrons soutiennent leur
mouvement les infirmières ont à coeur de
ne pas compromettre la qualité des soins
mais il est évident que plus le conflit
dure plus le fonctionnement quotidien
des services hospitaliers devient
difficile c'est ce que daniel duigou a
constaté à l'hôtel dieu à paris
une nouvelle journée de grève
aujourd'hui à l'hôtel dieu dans le hall
d'accueil les aides soignants décide de
se mobiliser avec les infirmières les
kinésie et les manipulateurs
radiologiste mail à 100 mètres au même
moment dans le bloc opératoire une
urgence est assuré comme d'ailleurs on
était toutes les urgences depuis le
début du conflit la règle générale c'est
l'entente entre médecins et infirmières
pour sélectionner les maladies assurer
les priorités ainsi cette équipe en
chirurgie elle établit au jour le jour
le tableau des interventions cette
semaine sur la vingtaine environ
d'intervention programme et nous n'avons
retenu que quatre tout prenez pas un
risque en reculant un certain nombre
d'interventions
on peut pas le nier c'est pour cela que
la grève est éprouvante pour tout le
monde et nous en sommes tous conscients
le personnel infirmier aussi certains
services fonctionnent donc seulement à
20 % de leurs capacités et c'est
pourquoi la direction commence à
s'inquiéter des conséquences de la grève
sur tous elle devait se poursuivre dans
toute entreprise en arrêt de travail
soit un coût financier notamment bon il
est clair que c'est pas dramatique pour
l'instant puisque l'assistance publique
un activité en forte hausse depuis début
d'année puisqu'elle % en nombre de
malades soignés par conséquent la grève
ne va pas entamer l'activité globale de
l'assistance publique
une autre coup c'est le coût social dans
les pires est une entreprise copro une
entreprise de marge que s'il ya une
cohésion interne sur les gens se battent
se sont opposés à skyrock
toute grève un coût mais le travail des
infirmières nous a répondu le personnel
a aussi un prix